THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE
A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO SERVAN TEMAS CHAU
CHAVEZ CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DAHLE
DALY. EGGMAN FLORA. FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER.
KALRA KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO STEINORTH.
STONE.
THURMOND AND TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA. REPETITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
YESTERDAY. MANY OF US WATCHED
THE SUPERBOWL GAME THAT WENT
DOWN TO THE WIRE.
THE HEAVILY FAVORED PATRIOTS
ONCE AGAIN. TRIED TO COME FROM
BEHIND WITH MINUTES TO GO.
HAVING WITNESSED THEIR SUPERBOWL
WINNING HERO X. LAST YEAR. I
STILL FELT ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
ALTHOUGH THE EAGLES WERE HAD BY
EIGHT POINTS.
AS I MENTIONED LAST YEAR.
THIS IS WHY WE LOVE OUR GAMES.
FOR UNLIKE LIFE.
THE RULES IN OUR GAMES ARE
CLEAR.
THE BOUNDARIES ARE SET. AND
WITHOUT DOUBT YOU KNOW EXACTLY
WHEN THE GAME WILL AND.
EVERY PLAYER AND EVERY COACH
NEW.
THAT IF THEY'RE GOING TO PLAY
THEIR VERY BEST
THEY HAD TO DO IT RIGHT NOW.
TOMORROW. NOT NEXT WEEK. NOT
NEXT SEASON. THIS WAS IT.
EACH DAY WE AWAKE.
WE ARE IN THE MOST IMPORTANT
GAME OF ALL.
AND LIKE THE PLAYERS IN
YESTERDAY'S SUPERBOWL.
THE WAY TO LIVE OUR LIVES THE
VERY BEST WE CAN.
HE IS REALIZING THAT EACH DAY IS
OUR FOURTH QUARTER.
EVERY MOMENT MIGHT BE OUR TWO
MINUTE WARNING.
INSTEAD OF SAVING OUR BEST FOR
ANOTHER DAY.
LET US TRY TO LIVE BEING OUR
BEST SELVES EVERYDAY.
WE KNOW IT MAY NOT FULLY SUCCEED
EACH DAY.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
JUST TO TRY.
IF WE TRIED LIVE EACH DAY WELL.
I CANNOT HELP BUT IN TIME. LOOK
BACK ON A LIFE WELL LIVED.
NUMBER ONE.
GRATITUDE AND KINDNESS BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MORE
SUSHI.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JAN TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN RECENTLY
MET AT NINE THIRTY A. M. ANIMAL
ANTHONY RENDON SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING. CHIEF
QUICKIE DOT THEN WILSON AT THE
DESK READING QUICK KATHLEEN I'M
LUIS READING. THE ROLL WAS
CALLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
MOVED A QUORUM CALL THE ASSEMBLY
MOTION CARRIED TIME AT NINE
FORTY EIGHT A. M. THE SPEAKER
DIRECTOR THE SERGEANT AT ARMS TO
CLOSE THE DOORS AND TO BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT NINE
FIFTY A. M. SPEAKER RENDON
DECLARED A QUORUM OF THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDENT. THE ROLL
CALL WAS COMPLETED AND THE
FOLLOWING ANSWER TO THEIR NAMES.
ACOSTA AGUIAR CURRY ARAMBULA
BAKER BERMAN BIGELOW. BLOOM
BONTA BROUGH BURKE CABALLERO
CARILLO SERVAN SAYS CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN CHIU CHOI CHU.
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY. EGGMAN FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE. LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MELENDEZ MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA. REYES
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
STEINORTH STONE THURMOND TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
UPON INVITATION SPEAKER RENDON
THE FINE PRAYER WAS OFFERED BY
SIMPLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB
OSHITA.
UPON REQUEST OF SPEAKER RENDON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL THEN
THAT THEY SIMPLY IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
FURTHER READING OF THE JOURNAL
OF THE PREVIOUS LEGISLATIVE DAY
WAS DISPENSED WITH ON MOTION OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA SECOND IN
BY FAMILY MEMBERS ALLEY.
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT THE
FOLLOWING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED THESE OF ABSENCE ON THE
DAY. ON LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON ON
PERSONAL BUSINESS AND WAITING
PRETTY AND AS A MEMBER TRAVIS
ALLEN. ON PATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
PURSUANT TO THE ASSEMBLY ROLES
THE FOLLOWING EXPLANATION OF
ABSENCES ORDERED PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. GENERAL NINE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
DEAR SPEAKER RENDON I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST PERMISSION
TO BE EXCUSED LEGISLATIVE FLOOR
SESSION ON THURSDAY GIANT PLATE
THAT TWENTY EIGHTEEN. TO THE
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
REQUEST. PRINCE YEARLY MISTER
BONTA MOVES.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
NOW THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING. TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND FOR ILLNESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MIGUEL SANTIAGO.
AND MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE. AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MORE SUJI AND LIMON TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ON RECONSIDERATION ITEMS TWO
THREE FOUR AND FIVE ARE
CONTINUED.
MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO SENATE THIRD READING.
SENATE THIRD READING ITEMS EIGHT
NINE AND TEN PASS AND RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE. TAKING A
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN ON
SENATE THIRD READING.
THIS IS SP FIVE EIGHT ONE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CORKERY WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE NUMBER
SANTIAGO.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
SPEAKER THE AMENDMENTS TO S. B.
FIVE EIGHTY ONE WOULD CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA EXCELLENT EXPAND TO
ACCEPT CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
STATE FOR PUBLIC PURPOSES AND
ALLOW TAXPAYERS TO. DESIGNATE
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR SPECIFIC
PURPOSES SUCH AS PUBLIC CATER
TWELVE SCHOOLS PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION OR STATE PARKS.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ALSO TO
INCLUDE PROVISIONS TO BACKFILL
THE GENERAL FUND IN MAKE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT HOLE
FOR THE TAX CREDIT CREATED IN
THE COMPANION BILL S. B.. TWO
TWO SEVEN AND JOINED S. B. TWO
TWO SEVEN AN SP FIVE EIGHTY ONE
SO THAT ONE CANNOT BE ENACTED
WITHOUT THE OTHER RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINCE AND
BACK ON FILE
OKAY MEMBERS.
LOOKING AT ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
THIS IS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
ACR ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
CHOI RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OLYMPIC WINTER GAMES
AND PARALYMPIC WINTER GAMES.
MS QUIRK SILVA YOU MAY OPEN ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH COMMANDS
SOUTH KOREA FOR HOSTING THE
TWENTY THIRD OLYMPIC WINTER
GAMES AND THE TWELFTH.
PARALYMPIC WINTER GAMES.
THE PURPOSE OF THE LYMPICS AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES IS TO PROMOTE
PEACE AND UNITY AND THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY THROUGH
SPORTS.
MANY OF US REMEMBER SITTING BY
OUR TV'S.
EVERY FOUR YEARS AS WE WERE ABLE
TO SEE NOT ONLY THE WINTER GAMES
AND THE SUMMER GAMES MANY OF US
FOLLOW THOSE ATHLETES STORIES
FROM COUNTRY TO COUNTRY. KNOWING
THE HARD WORK THAT THEY'D
INVESTED TO GAIN A SEAT AT ON
THEIR OLYMPIC TEAM. THESE
ATHLETES CAME WITH DREAMS THEY
CAME WITH HOPE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR PROGRESS
WOULD BE NOTED AND THEY WOULD BE
REWARDED WITH THE MEDAL FOR
THEIR COUNTRY.
THIS SAME THEME IS TRUE OF
AMERICA THE LAND OF OPPORTUNITY.
IN MY DISTRICT LA PALME WHICH IS
ONLY ONE MILE.
LONG WE HAVE AN OLYMPIC ATHLETE
HEADED TO THE OLYMPIC WINTER
GAMES THIS YOUNG ATHLETE A
FEMALE IS GOING TO THE OLYMPICS.
TO COMPETE ON THE US SKI TEAM
WITH SNOWBOARDING.
HER NAME IS KHLOE KIM.
SHE IS ABBASID A SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD FROM THE PALMER AND SHE IS
EXPECTED TO MEDDLE IN THE GAMES.
THIS STORY OF HER RISE IN
SNOWBOARDING CAME WITH HER
FATHER JOHN JIM KIM.
WHO YEARS AGO WANTED TO TRY
SNOWBOARDING?
WHEN IS THE WIFE REFUSED TO JOIN
HIM HE INSTEAD BROUGHT CHLOE'S
WHO AT THAT TIME WAS FOUR YEARS
OLD TIM THE MOUNTAIN HIGH RESORT
IN SOUND BURN A DINO.
SHE WAS FEARLESS EVEN AT FOUR
YEARS OLD AS HIS DAUGHTER SKILLS
CONTINUED TO BLOSSOM JOHN
DECIDED TO QUIT HIS JOB. AS AN
ENGINEER HE WENT HOME AND TOLD
HIS WIFE I'M DONE WORKING I'M
GOING TO MAKE MY DAUGHTER AN
OLYMPIAN.
JOHN WOULD DRAG HIMSELF OUT OF
BED IN THE EARLY MORNING BUT
ONLY HIS DAUGHTER INTO THE CAR
AND LET HER SLEEP AS HE DROVE
HOURS NORTH TO MAMMOTH LAKES.
THERE'S IS THE STORY OF LOVE
DEDICATION PERSEVERANCE AND I AM
SURE THAT THERE ARE MANY MORE
STORIES JUST LIKE THAT WITH OUR
OLYMPIANS THAT WILL COMPETE
STARTING THIS WEEKEND.
LAST WEEK I SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF
WOMEN'S SPORTS
AND TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THESE GREAT GAMES MP YOUNG.
SOUTH KOREA WHERE A YOUNG WOMAN
HAS FOLLOWED HER DREAMS AND
RISEN TO BE AMONG THE BEST IN
THE WORLD.
I JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
IRVINE TO COMMEND SOUTH KOREA
FOR HOSTING THE GAMES AND THE
NAME OF A MORE PEACEFUL WORLD.
AND FOR HOSTING CHLOE KIM A
YOUNG KOREAN AMERICAN WOMAN FROM
APAMA AS SHE FOLLOWS HER DREAMS
AND INSPIRES ALL YOUNG GIRLS TO
DO THE SAME WITH COURAGE AND
EMPOWERMENT.
WHO DOESN'T REMEMBER THE FAMOUS
LINE FROM OUR NEWSCASTER JIM
MCKAY?
THAT AS THOSE SKIER SKIED DOWN
THE SLOPE THE THRILL OF VICTORY.
AND THE.
AGONY OF DEFEAT MEMBER SO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATE IN THE
OLYMPIC GAMES IN SOUTH KOREA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA.
SEEING NO.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION AND MS QUIRK SILVA
RESOLUTION.
THE FIRST RULE WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON ACR ONE FIFTY
SEVEN CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS ITEM SEVEN ACR ONE FIFTY
FIVE IS PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING NOW BACK UP TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB FOR A THREE.
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FLORA THREE BY SOME THE
MEMBER MELENDEZ AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY INTO LEGISLATURE
DECLARING THAT URGENCY THERE
OUGHT TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MEMBERS IF YOU'LL PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION ACT
PROVIDES PROTECTION TO STATE
EMPLOYEES IN THE EXECUTIVE AND
JUDICIAL BRANCHES REPORT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OTHER ILLEGAL
BEHAVIOR? TURNER SUCH
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED TO
LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO DECIDE
BETWEEN KEEPING THEIR JOB OR
REPORTING ABUSE
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY WHICH
YOU VOTED ON SEVERAL TIMES WILL
GREAT WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION
TO LEGISLATIVE STAFF. BY
PROHIBITING ANY LEGISLATOR WORD
LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEE PER
METALLIC FROM RETALIATING
AGAINST ANY PERSON FOR REPORTING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR ANY OTHER TYPE OF ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY ACTIVITY. AB FOR A
THREE PROTECTS ALL STAFF FROM
ACHIEVE IN THE OFFICE DOWN TO
THE IN TURN AND AN URGENCY
BECAUSE HAS BEEN ADDED SO THAT
VICTIMS DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
MONTHS LONGER FOR THIS
PROTECTION TO TAKE EFFECT.
THEREFORE COLLEAGUES IT IS WITH
URGENCY THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB FOR A THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I WILL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MENACE WEAKER.
I'M A STRONG BELIEVER THE
TRANSPARENCY IS ALWAYS THE RIGHT
APPROACH.
WE SHOULD HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE
OR BE AFRAID OF.
TRUST ME I KNOW THAT SOMETIMES.
ALLEGATIONS COULD MAKE GREAT
HEADLINES.
AND SOMETIMES EVEN MINOR
MISUNDERSTANDINGS CAN CREATE
GREAT TURMOIL.
BUT WE SHOULDN'T LET THAT STOP
US FROM ALWAYS DOING WHAT IS
RIGHT. AND WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIANS ARE SMART BILL SEE
PAST THE HEADLINES IN THE LONG
RUN WILL ALWAYS GET THE FACTS
STRAIGHT.
THIS BILL PROTECTS INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO COME
OUT AND SPEAK AGAINST
WRONGDOING.
AND WE ALL NEED TO BE BRAVE AS
WELL.
IF YOU PASS THIS BILL AND WE
SHOULD GIVE EVERYONE.
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I STAND AS A CO AUTHOR
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE
ELSINORE IS BILL A. B.. FORA
THREE.
TO SAY THAT WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTION IS HERE FOR
LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
NO ONE SHOULD BE INTIMIDATED OR
THREATENED TO COME FORWARD IF A
VICTIM.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ABUSE.
AB BUT THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH.
TIME IS UP.
TIME IS UP ON HARASSMENT
INTIMIDATION AND RETALIATION.
TIME IS UP AND NO LONGER WILL
EMPLOYEES NEED TO BE AFRAID.
TO COME FORWARD.
TIME IS UP.
ISN'T JUST THE HASH TAG.
IT'S NOW A FACT.
THINK YOU TO THE BRAVE AND THE
COURAGEOUS WHO CAME FORWARD
KNOWING THEY MIGHT NOT SEE
JUSTICE BUT DID IT ANYWAY.
AND THANK YOU TO MY ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUE.
FROM JUST NORTH OF MY DISTRICT
LAKE ELSINORE. FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO AB FOR THREE
THROUGH THESE YEARS.
AND THANK YOU FOR MEMBERS.
FOR AGREEING WITH ALL WOMEN WHO
ARE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WEARING
BLACK THAT WE ARE DONE WITH
HARASSMENT AND TRULY TIME. IS
UP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOR A THREE.
THIS MEASURE IS CRUCIAL IS A
CRUCIAL FIRST STEP IN ENSURING
OUR EMPLOYEES THE OTHER FELLOWS
AIDS INTERNS OR OTHERWISE.
FEEL SAFE WHEN DISCLOSING
INSTANCES OF HARASSMENT I WANT
TO COMMEND THE EFFORTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE ELSINORE IN
NOT GIVING UP THE FIGHT IN THIS
PROBLEM FOR FOUR YEARS. RECENT
HISTORY HAS COIL CLEARLY SHOWN
OF THE MEASURE. THAT THE MEASURE
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY OPERATED
UNDER ARE NOT ENOUGH WE MUST
REMAIN COMMITTED. TO LONG NEEDED
INSTITUTIONAL CHANGE IF WE ARE
TO PROVE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE HOLD OURSELVES TO THE
HIGH STANDARDS OUR POSITIONS
CALL FOR.
I RAN FOR THE SEAT TO ENSURE
THAT WOMEN ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF
COLOR HAD A SEAT AT THE TABLE
WHERE DECISIONS WERE BEING MADE.
I WILL CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE ON
THIS ISSUE NOT ONLY FOR STAFFERS
IN THE CAPITAL.
BUT FOR JANITORS FARMWORKERS
HOTEL WORKERS UNDOCUMENTED
WOMEN.
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND ANYONE
ELSE'S FELT VICTIMIZED AND
UNHEARD.
THIS TYPE OF HARASSMENT WILL NOT
TURN EASILY.
BUT IF WE COMMITF. STATE TO
LONG TERM CULTURAL AND
STRUCTURAL CHANGE.
THAT WE MAY BE ABLE TO START THE
PATH OF TRUE PROGRESS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO JOINING THE
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION AND
RETALIATION. THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND THE REST OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN CONTINUING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AND AS I'VE
SUPPORTED FOR MANY YEARS LIKE SO
MANY PEOPLE ON THIS FLOOR I'M
GLAD I HAD THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM LAKE ELSINORE HAS CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS CONTINUE IMPROVE
THE BELL AND THAT WERE BEING
ABLE TO. HAVE IT ENACTED
HOPEFULLY
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT THOUGH
THAT IT'S A FIRST STEP AND IT'S
AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
BUT I DON'T WANT ANY OF OUR
STAFF OR ANY OF US TO FEEL
ASSURED THAT WE'VE COMPLETED THE
PROCESS.
THE TRUTH IS OUR STAFF IN THIS
BUILDING ARE STILL AT WILL
EMPLOYEES.
AS SOMEBODY WHO CAME FROM
ORGANIZED LABOR AND UNDERSTAND
DEEPLY THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
OUT WELL EMPLOYEES AND THOSE
THAT HAVE PROTECTIONS OF EITHER
CIVIL SERVICE. AND OR MORE
IMPORTANTLY A UNION CONTRACT IT
STILL LEAVES THEM VULNERABLE.
THERE'S ANOTHER THING THAT DOES
NOT HAPPEN IN THIS BILL THAT
WOULD BE TOUGH TO PUT IN BUT ONE
THAT WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT. AND
THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE A
PRESUMPTION SO WE HAVE CERTAIN
LAWS WE PASS WHETHER IT'S PAID
SICK DAYS WHETHER IT'S
IMMIGRATION RELATED OFFENSES
THAT SAYS THAT. AFTER A
COMPLAINT IT IS IS.
IS I WATCHED OR AFTER CITY HAS
TAKEN THAT YOU HAVE A
PRESUMPTION FOR A NUMBER OF DAYS
THAT IF YOUR RETALIATED AGAINST
THAT IT'S BECAUSE OF THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE. THE ONE TO
PROVE THAT IT WAS BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT'S WHAT A PRESUMPTION
IS A LOT AND ONE THAT WE NEED
WHEN IT COMES TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT NOT ONLY IN THIS
BUILDING. BUTTON AND WORKFORCE
AT LARGE
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
FEATURE BECAUSE SOMEBODY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SAY YES I WAS
LATE THIS WEEK.
I AM BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT IT WAS
LAST WEEK WHEN I LODGED A
COMPLAINT. FOR Y. AMBIEN
RETALIATED DANCE SO IT'S A IT'S
A LEGAL CONCEPT IN ONE WHICH
WE'VE IF YOU'RE TO BE FORTY ONE
WHICH I WOULD. HOPE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT AS SOMETHING WE COULD PUT IN
PLACE HERE.
AND FINALLY I'D SAY THIS I'M
GLAD WE'RE TAKING CARE OF SOME
BUSINESS IN OUR HOUSE IT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED DESPERATELY
NEEDED BUT WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST STATED.
THAT THERE ARE WOMEN IN EVERY
INDUSTRY WHO DON'T EVEN HAVE
THIS BASIC PROTECTION WHO HAVE
BASICALLY NO PROTECTION AGAINST
RETALIATION FOR CLAIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. AND I HOPE WE'LL SEE
THE SAME BIPARTISAN SPIRIT THE
SAME STRENGTH THE SAME
INDIGNATION ABOUT THOSE WOMEN AS
WERE SEEN ABOUT THE WOMEN HERE
BECAUSE THEY ALL DESERVE IT OUR
STAFF DESERVE MORE THAN THEY'RE
GETTING TODAY IN THE WOMEN OUT
THERE DESERVE. AS MUCH AS OUR
STAFF GET AS WELL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
WE'VE SEEN THIS BILL. THREE
TIMES I BELIEVE SENATE OVER TO
THE SENATE.
AND NOW GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE RECENTLY AND
SOME ATTENTION HAS BEEN PAID TO
THIS ISSUE. REALLY NATIONWIDE.
WE'RE NOW SEEING A LOT MORE
ATTENTION PAID THAN HAD BEEN
PAID IN THE PAST AND THIS BILL
NOW IS SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGED.
AND I I WOULD POINT OUT TO YOU
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS
IF YOU WOULD ON THIS BILL THE
FLOOR NOW HOUSES BECAUSE IT
POINTS OUT. SOME AREAS WHERE
THIS BILL STILL COMES UP A
LITTLE BIT SHORT.
WE'VE TAKEN SOME STRIDES AND I'M
GONNA ASK A MOBY EVERYONE WILL
VOTE FOR THIS TODAY.
BUT IT IS YET WORK. UNCOMPLETED
IN THE ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT SOME
OF THOSE AREAS BETTER REALLY
STILL BEFORE US TO TRY AND
SOLVE.
WE STILL HAVE TO MODERNIZE THE
LEGISLATIVE OPEN RECORDS ACT
STILL HAVE TO.
CLOSE SOME OF THE GAPS THAT ARE
BEFORE US IN THIS BILL AND IN
OUR PROCESSES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO BEFORE WE THINK WE'VE DONE
ALL WE NEED TO DO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD
COMPLETE THIS WORK OVER THE NEXT
YEAR HOPEFULLY.
IF NOT SOONER THAN THAT AND MAKE
SURE.
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE IS A MODEL
FOR HOW WE PROTECT OUR EMPLOYEES
HOW WE PROTECT AGAINST
RETALIATION THAT WE HAVE A VERY
OPEN AND FAIR PROCESS THAT IS
TRANSPARENT. AND IS IS
ABSOLUTELY PROTECTIVE OF THE
PEOPLE RE RELY ON ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS AS WE POSSIBLY CAN IF
WE CAN DO THIS AND THAT WE CAN
WORK TO ENSURE. THAT EVERYONE
ELSE ACROSS THE STATE IS AS
PROTECTED AS WE.
WE CAN MAKE OUR OWN EMPLOYEES
THAT'S A STANDARD WE'RE WORKING
TO SET HERE TODAY AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
PERSISTENCE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FROM LAKE
ELSINORE YOU'VE GOT IT.
NOR MAKE CHIU CHANGE IT DOES
TAKE PERSISTENCE OVER TIME.
I THINK THIS IS GONNA BE THE
FIRST STEP.
I AGREE THEY SHOULD NOT BE THE
FINAL STEP.
EVEN I.
DISAGREE THAT.
WE HE RETURNING IN THE STAFFERS
INTO A DUES PAYERS FOR ORGANIZED
LABOR THROUGHOUT THIS BUILDING.
BUT I DO THINK THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL FORMS NEEDED BY THINK
THIS IS AN OUTSTANDING BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE IRISH AND I'VE OF.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBER FROM LAKE ELSINORE FOR
PERSISTING AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
SEEN THIS ISSUE LONG BEFORE IT
WAS IN THE HEADLINES.
AND IT WAS AN ISSUE THAT WAS
AFFECTING STAFF ALL THROUGHOUT
THIS BUILDING THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT. AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE STAFF WHO HAVE WORKED HARD
EVEN THOUGH THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THESE PROTECTIONS.
I THINK THIS BODY ACTUALLY OWES
THIS INSTITUTION IN THIS BODY
PASSED THE BILL SEVERAL TIMES
THAT WE WE OWE AN APOLOGY TO THE
STAFF THEY HAVE LONG DESERVED
THIS PROTECTION.
AND THAT'S JUST A FACT.
AND I THINK THE MEMBER ALSO FOR
MAKING THIS A MEASURE THAT WAS
NOT.
A VEILED ATTEMPT TO PROTECT
MEMBERS.
OF REALLY TO GIVE THEM.
THAT THE STAFF THE VERY RIGHTS
THEY DO DESERVE.
BECAUSE STAFF OR AS WE ALL KNOW
THEY LOOKED OUT FOR US EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THEY WORK VERY VERY HARD EVERY
DAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE LOOK
GOOD WE DO BETTER WE SUCCEED IN
REPRESENTING OUR DISTRICTS.
EVERYONE OF US SHOULD HAVE THEIR
BACK THIS INSTITUTION SHOULD OF
HAD THEIR BACK LONG AGO.
AND THIS BILL IS A BIG STEP.
IN GETTING THAT THAT WAY.
AND THESE ARE STILL ON.
ULTIMATELY WHAT YOU KNOW THESE
ARE STILL STAFF THAT ARE GOING
TED NOT HAVE YET AN INDEPENDENT.
PRIVATE WAY WHICH THEY CAN RAISE
A CONCERN WHERE THEY FEEL LIKE
THERE ISN'T GOING TO BE ANY
PROBLEM THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE AND
GOING SOMEWHERE THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE BEEN SEEN. TRYING TO
LODGE A COMPLAINT THAT THEY HAVE
WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO IN THAT
AND HAVING AN INDEPENDENT PLACE
FOR THEM TO GO.
AND TO ANALYZE THEIR COMPLAINTS
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
TAKING ACTION.
BUT I THINK THIS IS A A
GIGANTIC STEP REALLY I THINK THE
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THAT
FORWARD.
ALSO ULTIMATELY WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS REMEMBER THAT WE AS
MEMBERS ARE ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO SET AN EXAMPLE.
ALL OF US ARE SUPPOSED TO SET AN
EXAMPLE.
AND MANY OF THE STAFF IN THIS
BUILDING OUR YOUNG THIS IS THE
FIRST JOB THEY HAVE WE ARE
ALMOST IMPRINTING ON THEM WHAT
IS APPROPRIATE OKAY BEHAVIOR.
FOR THEM TO TAKE TO THEIR NEXT
OFFICE.
OR THEIR NEXT CAREER AND IT'S A
DUTY AND RESPONSIBILITY OF US TO
ACT ACCORDINGLY.
AND.
NOT LEAVE THEM STANDING ALONE
WHEN THEY'RE IN A PLACE WHERE
THE GETTING UNCOMFORTABLE OR
BASICALLY BAD BEHAVIOR WAITING
FOR THEM TO BE THE ONES TO RAISE
THE ISSUE.
WAITING FOR THEM TO SAY GEE THIS
IS REALLY THE WAY IT SHOULD BE
GOING WE'RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
THEIR BACK.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
TAKE AWAY FROM TODAY IS YES
WE'VE GIVEN WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTIONS I HOPE THIS WILL GET
SIGNED IMMEDIATELY. AND YES WE
WILL KEEP WORKING ON THIS BUT
WE'RE THE ONES WHO NEED TO STAND
WITH THEM SO THERE ISN'T
SOMETHING THEY NEED TO BLOW THE
WHISTLE ON.
EVER AGAIN.
AND DON'T LEAVE THEM TO BE THE
ONES TO SAY SOMETHING FIRST.
AND TO THOSE WHO DID THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE THANK
YOU FOR COMING FOR WHEN YOU
DIDN'T HAVE THESE PROTECTIONS WE
WILL HAVE YOUR BACK.
THANK YOU AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY ARE
RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES ARE VERY PLEASED TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THE.
INSTITUTIONAL INTERESTS THAT WE
ALL HAVE THAT WILL OUTLIVE US.
VITAL MARC WE NEED TO MAKE ON
THIS TO CSUS MAKERS.
A PLACE WHERE YOUNG BRIGHT
PEOPLE.
WELCOME TO SUPPORT THE
MEMBERSHIP.
AND THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE TO
WORK ON THE FUTURE.
THE.
IN.
VERY.
DESPICABLE SORTS OF FACT
PATTERNS WE'VE HEARD.
ARE NOT JUST WRONG IN THEMSELVES
BUT THEY CAST A PALL ON
INSTITUTIONS SUCH THAT.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT THINK TWICE
ABOUT COMING TO WORK HERE.
PEOPLE THAT MIGHT HELP US
RESHAPE THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO. WE HAVE THE ONGOING WORK
THERE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRED BY
OUR PRESIDING OFFICER.
COLLEAGUE IN THE SENATE SENATOR
MITCHELL OUR OWN HOUSE SUB
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY. MY
COLLEAGUE.
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
.
BUT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL.
TO BEGIN ADDRESSING.
THIS BODY THE ENVIRONMENT WE
OFFER PEOPLE THE ASSURANCE THAT
THEY CAN COME HERE. BRING THEIR
TALENTS TO BEAR ON THE FUTURE
AND NOT BE DISTRACTED BY
SECONDARY MATTERS.
SO I JUST.
IN ALL OF OUR WORK WE SET THE
TONE OF THE INSTITUTION.
PEOPLE LOOK AT US INDIVIDUALLY
TO SET THE TONE INSTITUTION.
BUT THIS PLACE IS IN LAW.
RULES TO REINFORCE THAT.
AND IT'S NOT JUST FOR OUR GAVE
IT FOR THE FUTURE THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE. OF THAT THIS IS
A VITAL BREAK THROUGH AND I DO
HONOR YOU FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO. I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM A LAKE
ELSINORE FOR CHAMPION THIS ISSUE
FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
SHE'S BEEN A GREAT CHAMPION FOR
ALL THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
AND THE ISSUE AND THE CAPITAL
WILL BE A BETTER PLACE AND
BETTER PLACE TO WORK BECAUSE OF
YOU.
THIS BILL HOLDS PERPETRATORS
ACCOUNTABLE.
CREATES MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY
EMPOWERS VICTIMS TO COME.
FORWARD WITHOUT FEAR OF
RETALIATION.
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF.
MY CONSTITUENTS.
AND MY STAFF.
I AM PROUD TO BE A SUPPORTER OF
AB FOR A THREE AYE URGENT STRONG
AYE VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
FIRST I LIKE TO THINK.
THE AUTHOR.
WHY VALUE AS A DEAR SISTER IN
ARMS BOTH OF US BEING MILITARY
AND FOR HER PERSISTENCE?
ON THIS MATTER.
SECOND.
I LIKE TO THINK.
ALL THE WOMEN.
IN THIS HOUSE.
THAT HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS.
TO OUR STAFFS.
YOU SHOULD OF NEVER.
EVER.
HAD TO GO ONE DAY OF WORK IN
FEAR.
FEAR OF WHAT WOULD HAPPEN.
THERE ARE SEVERE INJUSTICES THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE.
YOU.
TO THIS ENVIRONMENT.
THE THINGS THAT HAVE TRANSPIRED.
IT IS MY HOPE MY PRAYER. THAT AB
FOR A THREE.
WILL HELP SETTLE SOME OF THAT.
THAT OUR STAFF AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF MEMBERS IN ALL
OF OUR OFFICES OF THIS
INSTITUTION.
CAN TAKE THAT STEP FORWARD.
TO PROVIDE THE ENVIRONMENT.
THAT THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE SHOULD
PROVIDE.
THIS IS GONE ON FAR TOO LONG.
THEY'RE MANY OF US THAT HAVE
BEEN IN POLITICS.
FEDERAL TO IT THERE ARE SOME
LIKE MYSELF THAT ARE BRAND NEW
TO IT.
I JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL MOVE
FORWARD.
WORKING TOGETHER.
TREATING EACH OTHER AS BROTHERS
AND SISTERS.
SHOOTING EACH OTHER WITHOUT
RESPECT.
THAT ALL EVERYONE IS TO.
IRISH AND I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
MEMBERS AYE RICE AYE AS THE
PRIOR COAUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
ONE I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
US LAKE ELSINORE FOR WORKING ON
THIS FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
ONE OF THE GMEZ OF KNOWLEDGE
OTHER WOMEN OR STAND IN THE
GALLERY AS WELL.
WEEK YOU'RE NOT STANDING ALONE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE THINK
ABOUT THE MOMENT THAT IN TODAY
IN TODAY'S HISTORIC AND THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WERE
PASSING. TO START TO GIVE SOME
SUPPORT AND FROM FIFTY TO OUR
STAFF BUT.
I THINK WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS
ABOUT SO MUCH POWER IN
HARASSMENT IS ABOUT AN IMBALANCE
OF POWER. ANYTHING ABOUT THE
WORK THAT WE STILL HAVE TO DO I
HAD THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO
SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS. THERE'S A
LOT OF GREAT IDEAS OUT THERE AND
I HOPE THAT WE COME AT IT WITH
AN OPEN MIND AND OPEN HEART.
AND A COMMITMENT TO MAKE SURE
WE ADD TO THIS PROTECTIONS THAT
WERE PASSING TODAY WHETHER THAT
ADDITIONAL.
WORK TO THIS BILL WHISTLEBLOWER
BILL WHETHER THAT'S WHEN WE'RE
CONSIDERING THE POSSIBILITY OF
OUR STAFF BEING UNIONIZED.
OUT WHETHER THAT'S OTHER
LEGISLATION THAT'S GOING TO
IMPACT NOT JUST ARE STATURE IN
THE BUILDING BUT OUR STAFF. ARE
WOMEN AND MEN ACROSS THE STATE.
REALLY THERE'S AN IMBALANCE OF
POWER ACROSS SOCIETY AND IF THIS
IS HAPPENING IN OUR BILLION
WHERE WE DO HAVE SOME POWER
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR WOMEN
WHO ARE WORKING IN SPACES LIKE
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY.
I DO FEEL.
WERE OUT THERE ARE HOTELS.
WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE THEIR
JOB THAT JOB?
IS THE PAYCHECK THAT KEEPS A
ROOF OVER THEIR FAMILIES HOUSES
AND FOR SO LONG HAVING HAD A
VOICE.
AND SO HOPE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WE TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
TODAY WE TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
ALL THE VICTIMS HAVE HAD THE
COURAGE. TO COME FORWARD TO HAVE
FIELD THIS MOVEMENT. REALIZE
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
AND WE COME WITH THAT THING OPEN
HEART AN OPEN MIND WITH ALL OF
THESE OTHER PROPOSITIONS THAT
ARE COMING FOR US.
IRAQ IS THERE ARE SOME GOOD
IDEAS OUT THERE IN THIS BY
ITSELF IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE ALL
OUR PROBLEMS.
BUT IT'S A BIG STEP BUT I DO
WANT TO THINK AGAIN OUR
COLLEAGUE UP FOR HAVING THE
TENACITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS OUT THERE. LA AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERSHIPS WORK
ON ON THIS AND I. FINALLY ONE I
THINK THAT BY CAMEL COMMITTEE
THAT'S OUT THERE.
THEY ARE TASKED
WITH WITH MAKING SURE WERE
ENGAGED IN THAT CONVERSATION. ON
AND THEY WERE NOT ENGAGED IN IT
ALONE THAT WAY AND GET TO THE
COMMUNITY THAT RAIN GAUGE AT
THEIR CONSTITUENTS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THROUGH THIS BILL
WILL FLEE OUR STAFF WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ENGAGED WITH US
SO WE CAN CREATE A BETTER SYSTEM
THAT WE COULD ALL BE PART OF
ACROSS THE STATE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF ABATEMENTS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
PLEASE IN GENTLEMEN IT HAS TAKEN
US FOR YEARS TO GET TO THIS DAY.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
MISTER SPEAKER.
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
LEGISLATION YUNIOR STAFF HAVE
BEEN PHENOMENAL TO WORK WITH I
DON'T I THINK THE BILL WOULD BE
WHAT IT IS TODAY. ABOUT YOUR
COLLABORATIONS I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
I ALSO WANNA THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR SUPPORTING THIS BILL FOUR
YEARS IN A ROW. AND THIS HOUSE
HIS STAND HAS STOOD UNITED ON
THIS ISSUE AND TO ALL THE CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
MEN AND STANDING WITH US TO TO.
SHIFT THE CULTURE IN THE
CAPITAL.
SO MONTHS AGO NEWS OF THE HARVEY
WEINSTEIN SCANDAL A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SCANDAL BROKE AND
WOMEN IN HOLLYWOOD TOOK A GIANT
RISK.
AND TOLD THEIR STORIES
AND THEY SAID THEY'D HAD ENOUGH.
AND SHORTLY THEREAFTER THE WE
SAID ENOUGH CAMPAIGN WAS FORMED.
OVER ONE HUNDRED FORTY WOMEN WHO
WORK IN SACRAMENTO. TOOK A
TREMENDOUS LEAP OF FAITH.
THEY WROTE A LETTER TO TELL
VARIOUS STORIES.
BECAUSE THEY TOO HAD SAID WE
HAVE HAD ENOUGH.
IF THEY HADN'T DONE SO I M.
CERTAIN WE WOULD NOT BE VOTING
ON THIS BILL TODAY SO LADIES
THANK YOU.
CALIFORNIANS IN THE COUNTRY THEN
LEARNED THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN
LITTLE SECRET SOCIETY OF VICTIMS
RIGHT HERE IN THE CAPITAL THAT
WE HAVE TOO MANY WHO HAVE BEEN
TOO AFRAID TO SPEAK UP BECAUSE
THE LAW OFFERED THEM LITTLE TOO
NO PROTECTION.
AND THERE IS A PRICE THAT IS
PAID ONE VICTIMS ARE TOO AFRAID
TO SPEAK UP.
COST IS THE LOSS OF ONE'S
DIGNITY.
THE LOSS OF ONE'S SELF WORTH AND
SELF CONFIDENCE.
THE STRAIN ON ONE'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEIR COLLEAGUES.
THE DESIRE TO SPEAK UP BUT BEING
TERRIFIED OF TELLING.
THAT HE'S.
AND THEN THERE'S THE ANGER THAT
IS FELT.
THAT THEY ARE IN A POSITION TO
EVEN FEEL THIS WAY IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
I PERSONALLY DO NOT KNOW A
SINGLE WOMAN IN THE WORKFORCE
WHO HAS NOT EXPERIENCED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AT SOME POINT DURING
HER CAREER I DON'T KNOW ONE.
NOT SO LONG AGO THERE WAS THE
WOMEN'S SEMINAR IT WAS ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT IN
WORKPLACE ISSUES THERE IS A
CROWD OF TWO HUNDRED WOMEN.
AND THE WOMEN WERE ASKED THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE BEEN THERE I'M
ON THE RECEIVING END OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HANDS.
AND THE WOMEN LOOKED AROUND THE
ROOM KIND OF CAUTIOUSLY. AND
SLOWLY ABOUT TEN OF THEM RAISED
THEIR HANDS.
AND THEN THE COORDINATOR OF THE
SEMINAR SAID NOW EVERYONE CLOSE
YOUR EYES DO NOT OPEN YOUR EYES
INTO YOU'RE TOLD TO DO SO.
AND THEY ASK THE QUESTION AGAIN
WHO HERE.
HAS BEEN THE VICTIM OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IN NEARLY EVERY WOMAN IN THAT
ROOM RAISE THEIR HAND.
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT WONDER IF
WE TOOK ALL THE WOMEN IN THE
CAPITAL.
THEY PUT THEM IN THE SAME
ENVIRONMENT IN ASKING THAT SAME
QUESTION HOW MANY WOULD RAISE
OUR HANDS HOW MANY. OF US WOULD
BE SURPRISED.
AND HOW MANY.
THERE IS TOO OFTEN A LEVEL OF
SHAME THAT COMES ALONG WITH
BEING A VICTIM. AND THAT NEEDS
TO STOP.
WE HAVE TO HONESTLY AM CONFRONT
THE CULTURE THAT MAY EXIST IN
OUR OWN OFFICES.
WHERE WOMEN PREDOMINANTLY BUT
NOT EXCLUSIVELY I'M HAVE BEEN
SEXUALLY HARASSED OR ASSAULTED
BELITTLED DEMEANED?
AND PUSHED OUT OF A CAREER ALL
TOGETHER WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THAT.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO JUSTIFIABLE
REASON WHY LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
DO NOT HAVE WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTION.
WE OWE IT TO THEM TO PASS THIS
BILL TODAY. IN IN DOING SO ALLOW
THE HEALING PROCESS TO BEGIN.
AND ALLOW TRUST
TO BE REBUILT.
WITHOUT I WANNA END WITH THE
WORDS OF JUDGE AQUI LENA WHO
PRESIDED OVER THE LARRY NASSER
ABUSE CASE.%
OF YOUNG FEMALE GYMNASTS
CAPITAL STAFF THIS MESSAGES FOR
YOU.
LEAVE YOUR PAIN HERE TODAY AND
GO OUT AND DO MAGNIFICENT.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK WILL YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
WHO WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO ON THE
URGENCY AYE SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
ON THE BILL.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
JOURNEY MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR THE ADJOURNMENT MEMORIES
MISTER MAYOR TUCCI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE.
DOCTOR LESTER SILVERMAN OF MEN
HAND BEACH.
DOCTOR SILVERMAN WAS A BELOVED I
DOCTOR IN DOWNTOWN MANHATTAN
BEACH.
HE WAS A.
PROPER TARIAN A PROUD CAL BEAR
NO PROBLEM LIBERAL.
THE GLASS IS THAT I'M WORKING
HERE TODAY.
WERE ISSUED BY DOC SILVERMAN
JUST
THREE WEEKS AGO.
BEFORE HE WAS TRAGICALLY LOST.
MUCH TOO SOON.
OF FROM A AT STUDENT.
OUT AT SEA.
DOCTOR SILVERMAN WAS VERY ACTIVE
IN THE MEN AND BEATS IN THE BE
AND BECAUSE HE WAS SO ACTIVE IN
BECAUSE HE WAS THE BILL OF IT UP
DOWNTOWN I DOCTOR IN MANHATTAN
BEACH.
IS A CELEBRATION OF LIFE THAT WE
JUST HAD LAST WEEK WAS ATTENDED
SEEMINGLY BY WAS HALF THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY OF MANHATTAN BEACH.
DOCTOR SILVERMAN IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE ANGELA AND IS TO
CHILDREN'S TO FEE AN AGING. I
ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED
IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
MOAN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
ALLEN GINTER MEN OF SANTA
BARBARA.
ALLEN PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY IN
HIS SLEEP AT THE AGE OF NINETY
FOUR.
ALLEN WAS A MEMBER OF THE SANTA
BARBARA LODGE OF THE NEIGHBORS.
AND THE LEADER OF THE WEEKLY
POLITICAL DISCUSSION GROUP THE
HEAT REVENUE AND NAMED THERE
AIN'T NO SUCH THING AS A FREE
LUNCH.
BORN IN TREMONT MODEST
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WINNIPEG CANADA
ALLEN MOVED TO LOS ANGELES IN
THE MID NINETEEN FORTIES. AFTER
COMPLETING HIS WARTIME SERVICE
IN THE ROYAL CANADIAN AIRFORCE.
WHILE WORKING FULL TIME AS A
TAXI DRIVER ALLEN PUT HIMSELF
THROUGH COLLEGE AND LAW SCHOOL
AT UCLA.
HE HAD A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
CAREER AS A WORKERS COMPENSATION
WORKERS COMPENSATION ATTORNEY IN
LOS ANGELES VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES.
FOR THE PAST SIXTY YEARS ALLEN
HAS BEEN WELL KNOWN IN SANTA
BARBARA MENTOR A COUNTIES AS A
GENEROUS SUPPORTER OF CHARITIES
AND NONPROFIT.
HE SERVED ACTIVELY ON THE LOCAL
BOARDS OF THE LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION THE FOOD BANK THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE A DL AND
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION ACLU.
I ALSO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING WITH ALAN ON THE BOARD
OF THE NEW BEGINNINGS COUNSELING
CENTER.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE SUSAN
AND FIVE CHILDREN. EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND HIS LOYAL DOG
TOTO.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF ALAN DETERMINE IF
SANTA BARBARA.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
FEBRUARY SIXTH CHECK CONCESSION
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH CHECK
IN SESSION THURSDAY FEBRUARY
EIGHTH FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BEAT HOUSE AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER GIPSON MOVES AND MISTER.
.
MISTER PATERSON SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTH
AT NINE AM.
THANK YOU.
WARM COLORS LIFTED